colin kaepernick reportedly wants to put
President Trump on the witness stand
Kaepernick is the quarterback who began
the NFL's kneeling protests during the
national anthem as you recall and Yahoo
Sports is reporting that Kaepernick's
attorneys want a subpoena Trump to
testify in his lawsuit against the NFL
know Kaepernick filed a grievance case
against the NFL after no team would hire
him
so does cap have a case let's debate
that with the Reverend Jesse Jackson
Reverend Jackson I don't think you and I
have talked since like 1998 so it's I'm
glad to have you on the show thanks so
much for being with us let's talk about
what is going on with this NFL these NFL
protests do you actually think that the
NFL a lawsuit that Kaepernick apparently
is going to file as grievance would be a
proper grounds to have Donald Trump the
President of the United States testify
and why we exercise his First Amendment
right to protest for his rights the
president really was about police
brutality that went unanswered run the
King beaten nearly to death without
consequences Diallo shot and killed in
New York by policemen without
consequences I have aluminum was jamming
the rectums and he's nearly bled to
death in New York or the case of Brown
in Ferguson Missouri and so somebody
said well don't black lives matter of
their consequences as to what's happened
to us and the kneeling was an appeal to
the flag in a peaceful protest they're
not burning or desecrating the flag out
in the field we've gone on these
appealing for the government to
recognize our right through it in 1965
so there's nothing harmful or
threatening about healing kneeling to
the flag no I understand what your point
of view is on that totally I get it but
what does that have to do with President
Trump testifying in a grievance against
the NFL
I mean how by interfering in the process
he has to convince his constituents of
the de facto boycott and the owners to
in fact put a penalty
before the players if they in fact use
well this opinion is northern their
opinion because he's the president we're
not gonna get past that because as a
legal matter that's just preposterous I
mean the president is not going to
testify in Kalen colin kaepernick suit
it's never gonna happen
his lawyer knows it's never gonna happen
his lawyer frankly should be sanctioned
if he actually tries anything like that
now the way for example he protesting he
used the filter for it the Philadelphia
Eagles who in fact did not take a knee
last year as a basis to turn the public
against a Jackson I would have had them
come to the White House if it was two
people or if it was one I would have
made a different decision but also I
think it would be fair if you and anyone
examining this would say you know if you
submit 80 names to the Secret Service
and then like three days later say oh
sorry we can't make it and like two
people in the mascot are coming and
we'll reschedule it when you're in
Singapore that's just lame they knew
that was LeBron James's temper they're
all saying we insulted by the the
violations of our people by this
president
what are you is that is there any good
news for black America under this
administration
do you like the unemployment like small
business he inherited a growing economy
when President Barack came in we lost a
thousand job that month in that game a
job for every month for years he
continued to grow
and they're still not because 54% of all
blacks make less than $15 an hour and a
significant by the militant end all
right now it's premature to determine
what's going to happen with this
provocative action toward Canada and
Mexico our neighbors will actually have
more manufacturing where people who
don't go to fancy colleges actually can
get a really high-paying job like they
used to when we actually had tariffs
that were put in place by Democrat
presidents and Republican presidents so
the tariffs thing just black it working
for half America have more month than
money
in fact the they have a job in Chicago
you have to go through 3 to 3
transportation transfers to get the work
transportation stood alone grid and
credit card millions of jobs were being
sent overseas due to globalization and
millions of jobs were being bled off to
countries like Mexico that was good for
black America because I call me crazy I
don't think that was good for
working-class people at all we lost
millions of jobs and this president is
actually bringing back jobs into the
United States and doing stuff like
prison reform with with Jared Kushner
and and others or working together
including with Democrats so it's from
what I can hear this president has done
nothing good for black America is that
what you're saying tonight nothing I'm
not saying that you keep cutting me off
but my point is that if you fit the four
percent of all black and make less than
$50 now you're the working poor and
you're working but you came before the
healthcare because you want to cut that
and shoot the month to the top one
percent working but you can't afford the
college education work and well he began
did not change the significantly enough
but the fact is unemployment 10 percent
down to down to 5 percent yeah now it's
at a record low the Atlantic
failed Americans president never pursued
policies bold enough to close the racial
wealth gap December 22nd 26% for 6
million Americans did not have it before
and they put it all
and rates are going out because the
system was unsustainable
look we could I actually think there's a
lot you could do with this president I
really think there's a lot you could do
to work with him on prison reform and
other issues I just think I think these
NFL players could work with the
president when you lock people up the
crack cocaine then you freed them up so
OPR is a health crisis so one goes a
house don't wanna go to jail of course
you should set people you were panelists
with President Trump right when he was
not a president you were pausing and
what happened well well until he changed
I mean here's the guy that looked at
five kids at the at the Central Park
five determined when they were declared
innocent they were guilty enough to be
executed here's a guy who looked at the
marches in Charlottesville Virginia
acquitted the marches for freedom with
the nods and clueless plan so he do you
think okay or we're glad you came on I'm
sorry we couldn't find more common
ground I think you could find it with
this president because I think he's
gonna do great things for black America